Hello, this is Dr. Cutters and you are completed my book. In this section we talk about some spiritual aspects that I think are the most important.
And I've alluded to them throughout the sections that you've read, and I really believe, and I don't know where you're at from a spiritual perspective, but we run a biblical based clinic here,
under our pastoral medical association license, so we are really a ministry, more than a clinic, and here to minister to your spiritual needs and more than anything.
We really believe that we as humans are spiritual beings, living out in this physical world, in a physical body, but it is really our spirit that will live forever.
You know, we are experiencing life now, but there is an eternity that we will spend forever and ever and ever, and we desire to be in heaven.
We believe that Jesus Christ is the way, He is the fulfillment of the covenant that was given to man by God for the sake of bringing us back into that right relationship with Him.
That same relationship that initially man had in the initial creation that we were, that was what our purpose is on earth is to have that right relationship.
I believe that we live in a fallen world, and cancer and disease is part of that fallen world, and it will only be completely overcome on the other side of death when we get to heaven.
And there will be no more sorrow and no more tears, and we will be enjoying His presence forever and ever and ever.
But on this side of heaven, we do have trials and tribulations that affect we are promised them, even the New Testament, that in these days all sorts of trials and tribulations will come, but do not be afraid.
Jesus said, I have overcome them. So we can only overcome even cancer through our relationship with Him, and I believe that trials and tribulations have a purpose in our life.
It is to drive us to a greater dependence upon Him, you know, all things.
We do not desire to create in this clinic a co-dependent relationship with any of our patients. We desire to point them to their Heavenly Father, who is the only one who can ultimately beat all their needs by Him.
And I do know Him, and I know He loves you above all things, and that's the most important thing that we can learn on this earth, that He desires to beckon us up onto His lap, and He desires to hold us and cuddle us, and go through our pain and sorrow with us, and know that we have, so that we can know that we have a Heavenly Father that loves us dearly.
If that's all you can gain from everything that we've done and talked about in these past sessions, then I believe that I believe that you're victorious, and that's ultimately we want that intimacy with God.
So I know that I'll be praying for you, I do pray for all my patients, and those that I'll never be, that I read my book every single day, and we will never stop doing that.
I ask that you pray for us, protections, so that we could continue to do what we do, and minister to those who need us, and we just give thanks to our Heavenly Father, and all things.
Thank you so much. I hope you enjoyed this.